drei Fanpages von mir nämlich Mona
Marlin und Jessie haben mir
Präsentationen
[Musik]
zugeschickt weder habe ich eine Ahnung
worum es in diesen Präsentation geht
noch warum die das überhaupt gemacht
haben aber wir schauen mal rein die
erste Präsentation handelt von Bibis
Beauty Palace Folie Nummer 1
[Musik]
Lebenslauf a das war
schon
durch mein schlagen hat sich einfach die
Präsentation ist weitergegangen machen
wir allerdings weiter mit der zweiten
Präsentation und zwar die Highlights aus
den Youtube Videos und Twitch Streams
von laserlaca extrem lustig da wird
wahrscheinlich nichts kommen wer ist
laserlaca ist nicht relevant deshalb
geht es weiter mit der näch Youtube
Highlights ist die nächste
Folie sch kommt da auch
nich
ich hasse euch so doll nächste
Präsentation geht über Tauben friedliche
Tiere Fragezeichen was wir über Tauben
wissen sie nerven weil sie überall drauf
kacken sie nerven weil sie einfach
nerven Frage an die Audienz hast du
schon mal ein taubenbaby
gesehen habt ihr schon mal ein
taubenbaby gesehen
nein woran könnte das liegen komplett
verzehrtes Bild auf der rech Seite
Tauben sind Drohnen der Regierung ja
weil Drohnen auch mit Haar geschrieben
wird die spionieren uns aus deswegen
nerven sie weil sie einen verfolgen
folgend der Aufbau einer solchen
Drohne habt ihr auch schon mal eine
Taube bei Nacht gesehen ich nicht die
fliegen dann alle zurück nach Berlin und
geben ihre ganzen wie du eine Toilette
richtig benutzt ich frag mich wirklich
gar nichts mehr was ist deine Toilette
Toiletten sind zum oder pissen da sie
besitzen eine Spülung wodurch die Kacke
und Pisse runtergespült wird so sieht
ein typischer Toilettengang
[Musik]
aus stark dass das Handy dann einfach da
unten reingefallen ist hier wird dann
auch noch mal der Toilettengang
dargestellt pinkeln dauert 10 bis 20
Sekunden kacken dauert 3 Minuten bis 2
Stunden kommt auf die Menge der an
manchmal schafft man es auch in unter
einer Minute zu kacken das ist mir neu
empfohlen wird das Handy mit auf Klo zu
nehmen wie du eine Toilette richtig
benutzt okay im stehen pinkeln am besten
neben die Toilette super Hose nicht
runterziehen ach mit angelassener Hose
super spülen sollte vergessen werden ja
ist ja unnötig wenn man e schon daneben
gepisst hat und nach dem Klo nicht die
Hände waschen okay haben wir wieder was
dazu gelernt die Klobürste ist auch nur
Z Dekoration da klobürst ne das ist da
auch nichts sinnvolleres bisher für gibt
am Ende noch ein paar Quellen damit ihr
nachschauen könnt dass alle
Informationen richtig
[Musik]
sind
ne bitte keine Fragen stellen danke und
bis zum nächsten Mal okay das nächste
Mal ist jetzt wir machen weiter mit der
nächsten Präsentation willkommen zu
meiner Präsentation über Haie okay Haie
kommen überwiegend aus ha
[Musik]
war richtig war echt lustig ma wir
weiter gehen Ernst an die ganze Sache an
es gibt Haiarten hammerhi laternenhi
tigerhi weißerhi zitronenhai ich glaube
die gibt sogar wirklich ne
das was hat der laternenheim ja
natürlich trägt der eine Laterne der
tigerheim genauso sieht einer aus der
weiß heiß extrem weiß und der Z
ja genau das ist der zitronenhei moin
servus moin machen wir weiter mit Fakten
über Haie wenn zwei Haie geboren werden
sind das
einhiige wir stellen uns vor das ist
eine Präsentation in der Schule so die
Ohren der Haie sind von außen nur als
winzige Öffnungen sichtbar sie können
schlecht erhören als andere Wirbeltiere
deshalb wird empfohlen ihnen keine
Kopfhörer zu
schenken interessanter Punkt Haie werden
Hai wenn sie Drogen nehmen okay manche
Haie sind für spezielle Methoden bekannt
um einen Partner für die
Heirat mein Partner für die Heirat
anzulocken ha begrüßen sich traditionell
mit einem High Five okay und können ihre
Beute beim Angriff Ort mit Hilfe der
Hightech Technologie interessant es
heißt ist dass Haie bis zu 400 Jahre alt
werden können das bezweifel ich weitere
Fakten männliche Haie werden als Heinz
bezeichnet und weibliche he werden als
Heike bezeichnet das
[Musik]
war's ja
Freunde menschlichesind ziemlich
abstoßen Tipps für eine gute
Präsentation oh wir haben einen
Übergang
lol das ist einfach
weggeflogen
okay kriegst du schon mal ein Plus mit
Sternchen Design Schrift wählen die man
gut lesen kann
cleanesin wählen und Schriftart nicht zu
klein auswählen okay super merken wir
uns wir hatten schon wieder ein Übergang
na was du auf jeden Fall beachten
solltest nicht zu viel in einen
Stichpunkt schreiben sonst werden zu
gelangweilt und schalten ab besser ist
es wenn man Stichpunkte kürz hält und
keine ganzen Sätze schreibt ein
Stichpunkt sollte nicht über eine Zeile
gehen damit die Folien übersichtig
bleiben wenn du merkst dass der
Stichpunkt zu lang wird mach lieber
mehrere Stichpunkte wenn es immer noch
zu viel ist hast du Pech gehabt außerdem
solltest du beachten dass du nicht von
Thema zu Thema springst sondern ein
Thema vollständig beendest und danach
mit dem nächsten startest somit wird ein
Durcheinander vermieten und die zer
können alle Themen besser
aufnehmen lol wir haben hier Übergänge
was ist denn jetzt los
Design stand nicht gerade schon Design
egal Design sollte so gewählt sein dass
man den Text gut lesen kann Hintergrund
auf jeden Fall gleich ja haben wir hier
auf jeden Fall auch am Start Übergänge
und Animationen wenn Übergänge zwischen
den Folen benutzt dann nicht zu viele
nur clean Übergänge sonst ist es too
much Animationen sollten ebenfalls clean
[Musik]
sein Sprache und rexsschreibung auf gar
keinen Fall Umgangssprache verwenden
diger und bitte alle Wörter korrekt
schreiben es wäre bodenlos wenn die
Kommasetzung falsch ist nicht nur in
Großbuchstaben schreiben das ist gottlos
diese Übergänge Länge Vertrag Vortrag
bei mindestens 30 Minuten sein also
brauchst du so 50 Folien wieder Übergang
Übergänge sollten nicht zu lang
sein
hallo
20387 Stunden
später ach das
war's während des Vortrags ständig auf
die Notizen schauen stottern ist wichtig
nicht verständlich reden am besten
nuschelst du keine eigenen Worte
benutzen das Ende der Präsentation am
Ende solltest du die Zuhörer immer
fragen ob Sie noch Fragen haben danke
für die Aufmerksamkeit Fragen sind
[Musik]
unerwünscht ja Freunde in dem Sinne
würde ich nur noch sagen wenn es euch
gefallen hat lass mal kurz
überlegen hm h warte kurz
ah ja noch mal gerechnet nein